look at the smile Nina's basically
saying Vancouver sucks oh you put it in
your mouth I know you chew the hot dog
with mustard man purchased an
[Music]
I love grandpa island lots of great
little shops artists ain't some cool
food but now we're gonna head back to
Vancouver over there and go explore the
city
[Music]
what do we get any now Darth Vader
outfit for Teemo the hot dog with
mustard and work just Ana Nina loves all
things OGG she gets excited by dogs
now what see she's distracted by dogs
right now Wow look at these guys
[Music]
look who we have a Starbucks Nina's
gonna go get to Starbucks tea
Payton's gonna get his bear costume
Nina's gonna get a tea
let's go Nina
[Music]
nina want some instant noodles all right
I think she's going for an instant
noodle I think she's gonna do it she put
it away what happened Nina so bad for
you all right I'm gonna I'm gonna quasi
help pick two more instant noodles like
you're there okay what is it is the
surprise instant noodle
[Music]
what do you think now now
you think so should we do it I know yeah
yeah not a lot of excitement here I'm
gonna be honest
[Laughter]
let's go let's go
[Music]
what do you think up here mister there
it is
are you sure holder did you buy some
National Bank stock all right
[Music]
was that good you like it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
famous steam clock I said everybody was
waiting for you got here just in time to
see it every half an hour it does its
own thing this is a good trip for Nina
that's not true actually Nina cares
about a lot of people we love you Nina
[Music]
okay time for the best tacos in
Vancouver Taco Fino let's go
[Music]
all right our own table band here nice
[Music]
okay Nina try that fish tacos first
that's what they're that's what they've
known for
[Music]
nice alright let's eat steak
salty and sweet what so is it good okay
last one the chicken oh you put it in
your mouth
I don't eat you how is it alright yeah
nice how you feeling nina was it yummy
nice
just enough yeah look at that smile we
love Dina we love you so much
aah squish squish her let's continue our
Vancouver adventure and head to
Chinatown oh look the gates of Chinatown
those are the gates of Chinatown
all right let's go in and see what we
got here wow this is pretty cool eh are
there fish bamboo that's cool
[Music]
oh cool look at those terracotta
warriors look at this sign we accept
walkins walk-ins
come on that's funny we're looking for
crackle cream to get some special treats
but the heavier x' is passion fruit
passion please a salted caramel minion
like that one excited you're gonna have
our creme brulee you're gonna have your
minion cookie cookie salted caramel and
it's coming
alright salted caramel and vanilla creme
brulee just give it a shot Nina stop the
caramel number one I'm sure I'm sure
okay how about you go for the regular
one also unsure not impressed
alright good well time to go boule good
you see the top of the tower Hayden so
here we where it's fre walk
all right we found another Halloween
store for Hayden let's see what we get
[Music]
what is that a bunny scary bunny that's
a pretty evil bunny Oh
[Music]
what's happening yeah I'm gonna get a
megabyte Pizza
[Music]
hey feeling you get the way back all
right so let's eat some pizza yeah
thumbs up all right good all right good
job
how's your pizza hainan all right
next stop is famous beef jerky place
there was this convenient company I was
on Dragon's Den dragons and it's the
shark tank equivalent of Canada actually
came up before shark tank and had Kevin
O'Leary and Robert Herjavec on it and
they invested into a beef jerky place
here they invested into a beef jerky
place here and the last time we came to
Vancouver he met insisted that I go get
her some of it and it was amazing and so
we're gonna go find the place we have to
drive there is it's coming in the middle
of nowhere we're gonna cab there get
some yummy beef jerky unlike that nasty
smoked salmon jerky that we had earlier
today whoo whoo that was bad
boom to the car to the turkey all right
we're here
let's get some jerky very exciting
christmas is here I like your shirt
you're awesome bkh jerky hmm oh my god
enough is loitering and mouth is
watering a mouth is watering its order
[Music]
[Music]
so juicy best trick you've ever had yeah
it's really good jerky so you do a
really good job here guys go to
Vancouver checked out bkh jerky
how is it yeah that's best jerk you've
had that's not even the jerky that's the
ends which are the jerky mmm delicious
amazing so that we came while I was here
I discovered that there is a famous ice
cream shop close by so we're gonna hit
that up before we go home and then we
have to eat dinner
we can't ruin our dinner with jerky and
ice cream but we're kind of going to
because we're on vacation
yeah here we are at earnest ice cream
seriously good
[Music]
it's all that's left of our pork yummy
cookies and cream cone that's a big cone
how was it yeah that's a little bigger
than I anticipated
bigger than Nina's face you want to try
when is cream and the other is help the
caramel all right Cheers Hayden ice
cream Cheers
yeah I hate the squat how about here
mister
you don't think you're eating dinner I
think I mean in dinner I just had we had
a whole bag of pork turkey and a double
scoop ice cream and I'm feeling excited
cause he's squeezing my finger
I'm feeling very ready to go have a huge
dinner amazingly ready to have a huge
dinner okay what's the plan we gonna go
home quickly relax a little bit and then
go eat dinner ready why do you feel bad
what do you mean you feel bad
oh you're full you ready for dinner
that's all okay good time relaxing it's
coming up on seven o'clock which means
if we are gonna get out before Hayden
goes to bed we need to go down everybody
is just massively starving like just you
know pretty pity for cows each each
exercise oh yeah what
we're gonna go get some ramen cuz Nina
loves soup look at this round look at
that sounds gross
are you ready for a whole new ramen
experience let's go to the ramen man
starting off with some karaage fried
chicken
[Music]
don't eat the sausages don't go home
[Music]
this is the best yeah is it good all
right juicy good
the ramen came that's what we're here
for the soup
[Music]
super-scared thumbs up thumbs up how's
this one
[Music]
thumbs up all right yeah we have a happy
Nina let's eat happy wife is happy life
a happy son is happy
[Music]
but happy son happy bun
how we feelin guys really
was it a whole new ramen experience like
the sign says it's goodbye like our
lucky
[Music]
you like that you see in Toronto ramen
it's better than Vancouver ramen Wow
just like that you're gonna you're gonna
dis spank uber Nina's basically saying
Vancouver sucks
[Music]
she wasn't paying attention was trying
to beat her okay we're nothing we love
you we love you Nina you're so special
okay we're gonna go maybe get some
dessert and head back to the condo
to relax and send hate into bed okay so
guys it's been a crazy day we've been
we've been we've tried a lot of food
we've seen a lot of things what's what's
the theme or the message of the day what
do you guys got what do you got oh my
gosh something serious something serious
message of the day theme of the day what
do you got yeah that was good
grandma was good Nina what do you got
try everything that was pretty good
Hayden you got something else sure okay
good Granville Island Pizza says hate it
I think for me lesson is we had a plan
but we deviated from the plan and we're
open to uh let's see me doing she's
she's she's proving my point here being
open to deviating from the plane and
seeing where the world takes you I think
right from the start when Nina took over
and we ended up going on the ferry
instead of walking and the ferry ended
up being awesome and then we took some
detours and we did some things that were
playing but we had a lot of unexpected
surprises today and I think often when
things don't go to plan we we get
negative we get frustrated we get angry
but if you just maintain a positive
attitude and look at how you can turn
into something and special you might get
the most special things of all time like
what's happening right now
love to take over Ellen so that's our
video pain is gonna go to bath time bath
time for sure bath time I'll hold on
hold on I need to okay who I had to get
that cough at this is a wet cough - guys
it's really wet cop yeah so if you guys
want to see day one of our trip the link
is right there next to us and think
you'll enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]